first of all I want to join others in
welcoming all of you from electricity
lift off to Colombia we have a long
partnership with EDF in the University
and that my school School of
International and public affairs it's
been a very fruitful partnership for us
and we're delighted that you're here
that you all made it in the same at the
right time in the right place so I want
to thank also those who have been
responsible for organizing this event I
know Alicia and Lauren have already
thanked you for coming but i want to
thank them for all of the arrangements
they made is Marta vaccarella here ah
Martha as you know is a as a PhD in
Colombia and economics and worked with
Jeff heal and in NC pandith business
school she's a expert on climate change
so she's part of your group and I'm well
but delighted to welcome you back to
Colombia again the Alliance Program it
says here very clearly enjoys a very
special status set Colombia and i can
tell you why alliance program is part of
is only one of two institution level
agreements that we have with other
universities around the world so what
that means is that what EDF has been
supporting that is the Alliance program
is a program that involves every part of
Colombia all of our 9 professional
schools and the Arts and Sciences which
include the doctoral programs and our
undergraduate college as well this means
that it's the most important program I
think of academic and cultural exchange
that we have with any other part of the
world and it brings Colombia together
with three French institutions who are
wonderful partners Alicia and her
predecessors have made sure that the
program has gotten off the ground well
and it involves both student exchanges
dual degree program and dual degree
programs as well as exchanges of fact
professors so it's a and the professors
and students come from all parts of the
university so for us it's been a
wonderful way to reintroduce our
students to France and to French
institutions and to welcome to Colombia
a series of faculty professors and
experts and students as well from three
of Francis great institutions we don't
have enough French and French students
and French faculty at Columbia so this
has helped us to make up for a
deficiency that we all recognize but we
couldn't possibly do anything to repair
until EDF and Alliance came along I
should say that one of the duties I
inherited on becoming the interim
provost of the universe you know the
Provost is right a Provost it was
explained to me when I moved into the
office is the university's chief
academic officer so I'm responsible for
programs that have to do with the
intellectual quality of the institution
I have to approve every tenured
appointment to our faculty I'm
responsible for programs that involve
more than one of our professional
schools or departments and I'm
responsible for any institution to
institution agreements between Colombia
and other institutions around the world
so the Alliance Program actually reports
to me so I'm somehow I became their boss
in the last show so this is one of as
you can imagine at a great complex
institution like this one this is one of
the duties that I most enjoy there are
two kinds of people that come into my
office those that have problems they
want me to solve and those who have
solutions that they want me to bless and
I've never gotten anything but solutions
from there from the Alliance staff and
so I'm very grateful for that sepa the
school that I was happily running before
I was taken away to be the interim
provost the School of International and
public affairs has had a long
relationship with the Allianz program we
have a faculty exchange program with
oscilloscope in which a sample professor
comes to Columbia each year and one of
our faculty goes to see on spoke and
we've had a series of wonderful people
from sounds po most recently Ghassan
Salim a who taught one of the most
popular courses at sepa in the politics
the complicated politics of the Middle
East and several of our faculty have
gone there most recently the vice dean
Asifa Robert Lieberman who has was a
specialist on American social welfare
policies and race we also have a dual
degree programs with sales pope in which
our students take first year here and
then their second year at sea on spoke
and the same is true for their sales Pro
students so we have seen on supposed
students that are getting a master's
degree from seals po and from cipa and
from Columbia after two years in which
they take courses in both institutions
and it's been a wonderful popular
program in which a number of our
students have found that their careers
have taken off much more rapidly than
they might have expected had they've
received the degree only from cipa so
their ability to present themselves as
really international people who have
experienced a year the French
institution and done well has helped
them enormously and the intellectual
climate in the two schools is
efficiently different so that the two
schools each one adds something to their
education that they would not otherwise
have been able to acquire cephas also
benefited from EDF in another way we
have a center for energy marine
transportation and public policy which
is one of our chief research centers at
sefa and this is the center in which our
faculty do research on issues of global
energy security and political economy
and the EDF has been a wonderful
supporter of that Center over the last
several years as well so I want to say
something very warm about EDF support
for this major initiative etsy PO
the the engine that makes all this work
is of course the Alliance the aliens
endowment that is although conditions
may change and what we want to
accomplish at any moment in time may be
different in the future that it is now
the fact that we have an endowment that
in perpetuity supports relationships
between French institutions and Columbia
means that we will forever I mean yes
that's so much endowments or funds that
are created from which the institutions
that have them may spend only a portion
of the annual income but not the
principal so the aliens endowment is
invested with the rest of Columbia's
almost seven million seven billion
dollar endowment in the stock market I'm
pleased to report to you that the return
on our investment last year was in
excess of 23% in very difficult times so
the allowance has benefited from the
expertise that Columbia employees to
manage its funds it is garys donut
that's as of jun 30 i don't know
anything about what's happened over the
summer so so for the year ending june 30
we we managed more than twenty three
percent return but what that means is
that every year the university pays out
two units everywhere an amount based on
the returns over three years of this
fund and the Alliance will receive
forever a return on the endowment and
the funds that are invested as part of
the Columbia endowment to support its
activities from now and until the end of
time so this so the good thing about
having an endowment is that you don't
have to go back each year and beg for
money we don't ask any legislature to be
generous and and we don't have to go to
individual donors again at least for
that portion that's already here and
invested forever so having this
endowment has been tremendously
important for the other
we're hoping that it'll grow and grow
tremendously over time so that we can
support additional activities that the
ugly loss would propose to us if you
have any questions about Columbia
University that an interim provost could
possibly answer I'd be delighted to
respond but I want to make sure that you
all feel as welcome here as possible I
know that you've been running into a
number of our faculty who have been
presenting you with some of the results
of their research we could have doubled
or tripled the number of faculty who we
recruited for this purpose so you'll
have to come back so in the future you
can meet some of the ones that didn't
quite make it onto your very busy
schedule for these last few days so
thank you very much for coming and thank
you for your support that the audience
question I think is really interesting
for institutions in New York that speaks
absolute community here the policymakers
mayor in a way that we're not always
familiar ways in Europe our academic
institutions are somewhat small and also
let connected so community explain
what's your vision and how it's working
here well the largest number of
connections between Colombia and the
surrounding community and and the larger
policymaking community of the city and
then of the state and nation our
connections that are made every day by
individual faculty whose research is
relevant to some question of public
import and all of that activity is
completely uncontrolled I wake up every
morning worrying about what the
newspapers will say that well that a
member of my faculty has has done in the
last 24 hours said to the press or
reported in a in a research paper so
much of what we do perhaps most of what
we do to connect to the surrounding
community is done by individual faculty
members who pay absolutely no attention
to what Dean's and Provost's tell them
they should be doing and I suppose
that's exactly the way we want it but
the university has institutional ties
with the city with the state with the
country and internationally that are
reflected in some of the programs that
it that has developed over time perhaps
the most difficult for American
universities to establish positive
relations with their immediate
environment we refer to these problems
as town-gown relationships so the gown
that is the university we dress up in
funny gowns on graduation day the on the
side of the gown universities tend to
want to expand and by gobbling up
neighborhoods at the lowest possible
price and then ignoring their denizens
forever
on the other hand towns can to see
universities as not only a sources of
employment but also as places where on
Saturday evenings young people between
the ages of 18 and 25 misbehave and
where the institution adopts a kind of
imperialist attitudes towards its
surrounding towards its surroundings
that our times create all kinds of
problems Columbia's had a long sometimes
troubled and sometimes very positive
relationship with the surrounding
communities in the northern part of
Manhattan we have we occupy an enormous
part of what is called Morningside
Heights this part of Manhattan and then
if you go further north 40 blocks
there's the Columbia Medical Center and
the School of Public Health and there
are also huge huge presence in this part
of the city the most recent and
significant relationship relationships
that we've built with the community have
to do with the university's expansion to
the north where we've purchased about 18
acres so that's about seven and a half
fact area actors of land north of our
current campus in a part of the city
that's known as manhattanville and if
you go north of the university up to
about 120 fifth Street you will see a
giant hole in the ground with lots of
construction equipment the first phase
in the construction of this new campus
that will be devoted mostly to graduate
in research activities in the first
phase and delighted to say the School of
International and public affairs will
have a building the business school the
School of the Arts will have a theater
there'll be a small conference center
and the giant building you see going up
now is research institute in
neurosciences and much of the rest of
that 18 acre campus will be devoted to
science so in the process of acquiring
that property and communicating our
intentions to the surrounding community
we entered into discussions with what
are called in Manhattan local community
local community boards are citizens who
are elected by their neighbors to keep
watch on their communities to lobby the
city for more services to notice when
things are going wrong and to badger
city agencies to do better so what the
university did was to work with the
local community board north of the city
and enter into what is called a
community benefits agreement so that
over the next 20 years the university
will be supporting many of the
activities social activities and
cultural activities in the surrounding
neighborhood I think the total cost to
the university in kind and in money of
community benefits agreement that we
entered into is in the range of 60 to
100 million dollars so the first phase
of this community benefits agreement
will take shape when Columbia Teachers
College opens a demonstration school the
hope is that it will be able to operate
a public school in a way that
demonstrates other public schools in the
city how one can improve the quality of
primary and secondary education but
community benefits agreement also
contains provisions that require us to
hire contractors who are minority who
are from underrepresented minorities and
women for at least twenty five percent
of the total work that is done in the
construction of this new campus and it
requires us to consider applications
from people who live in the neighborhood
and who would like to work on those
projects there are lots of other
benefits that the community and and the
university agreed upon as part of this
expansion project so that's one way in
which the university interacts with its
immediate surroundings with respect to
the city state and national governments
most of that most of our interactions
have to do with the activities of
individual faculty but for example we
are just now preparing a major proposal
to the city government which issued a
request for proposals last February the
city government wants to support the
creation of new science and engineering
complex in the
city that would connect with businesses
and the city government in a way that
would create jobs and create a certain
dynamism in technologically progressive
areas of engineering and applied
scientific research so we're we're
planning to devote a part of the next
phase of construction in manhattanville
assuming that we win the contest to the
creation of a new data Sciences
Institute that would focus on areas like
health statistics on media on
cybersecurity on areas in which masses
of data have now become available
through the internet and elsewhere but
that in which our capacity to use the
data is still quite limited one of the
areas is smart cities that is the use of
masses of data to analyze and propose
solutions to City problems from traffic
to environment so another way in which
we interact is collectively to involve
portions of our faculty in this case the
Engineering and Applied Sciences faculty
and the business school to find ways
that we can work together to help
dynamite the city economy at the state
and national level the universe units of
the university enter into contractual
relationships that involve all kinds of
research from small groups of faculty
that advise the environmental protection
the protection agency on issues that had
to do with the environment to folks in
the business school that have contracts
with consulting contracts with a group
contracts with a private enterprise so
although the model for an American
university is to create a sort of campus
distinct from apart from and quite
different in aspect to the surrounding
community actually universities no
matter how enclosed they look in the
United States are really quite porous
and interact with society at all kinds
of little the long answer to a very
short even pointed question
and the else i'm terry at the university
you know we have about 25,000 students
about 6,500 are undergraduates and the
rest are graduate and professional
school students they're all very well
behaved except on saturday nights we
have one of the largest medical research
centers in the country we certainly have
the largest and best public policy
school anywhere in the world and how
many of you from EDF everyone every but
from different countries sure
test well I hope very much that you
enjoy your stay at Columbia in New York
please come back as often as you like we
haven't much more to tell you about the
University and lots more faculty who
haven't had a chance to meet you yet so
thanks very much for pleasure